[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHANE GLASS: So my
name is Shane Glass.
I am the program manager for
Google Cloud's public data set
program.
Yeah.
But more importantly,
today I get
to be the MC for Demo Derby.
So Demo Derby is
this, like, cool,
fun thing we do internally,
and it's a really neat part
of our culture.
Google's a really big
place, and there's
a lot of really cool things
happening across Google.
So this is an opportunity
for developers and people
that don't always
work together to get
to see the amazing work that
their teammates are doing
and get to better understand it.
So I will get out your way.
I know you guys are
here to see the fun.
I'm here to see the fun.
So without any further ado, let
me bring up our first developer
advocate, Billy.
[APPLAUSE]
BILLY: Long walk to the stage.
Hey, everybody.
I am Billy.
I am in developer relations
for Cloud Bigtable,
and I'm going to talk to my
demo of air quality, monitoring,
and analysis.
Cloud Bigtables are a massively
scalable, NoSQL database,
and it's perfect
for an IoT use case.
So we put sensors like this in
the back of a few Google Street
View cars and are
monitoring air quality live
right now actually.
We have a few cars right
on the road driving
around the San Francisco area.
Let me zoom in a little bit.
If we wait a few seconds, we can
actually watch it move around.
The data is streaming
in here through Pub/Sub.
We've got a 4G
connector on here.
It sends messages to Pub/Sub,
processes it with Dataflow,
and then write to Bigtable.
We also had a collection of
three years of historical data.
So we visualize that
as well and created
an interactive
dashboard with this.
Bigtable is perfect for
serving an application,
because you get really fast
writes and really fast reads.
So here we're able to look at
the past three years of data.
Let me see.
My zoom might be a little off.
So right now we're looking
at the ozone concentration.
We also have nitrogen
dioxide, and these cars
are driving all
over the Bay Area.
We can even check what
happens when they go out
a little bit farther.
Sometimes they just
stay in the area.
But you can really see we're
getting data at a street level
position, and this is
only some of the data
that I was able to visualize
without the map getting
too slow because there were
too many data points on there.
And also Bigtable, we have
the really fast reads,
so we're able to do training
directly on our data--
on our data in Bigtable.
We don't move our data to GCS or
another, kind of, fast storage
system.
So we're doing nitrogen
dioxide predictions
based on zip code and date.
So we can click
somewhere on the map
and get a prediction for
the nitrogen dioxide values.
And yeah, we can
also change the date.
In August or something,
you can see if it changes.
It's not-- we didn't do a
great job training the model.
We're really just trying to
show the proof of concept.
The Bigtable is great
for IoT workflow,
great for doing machine
learning on top of.
Here is some of the
architecture we've got going on.
Let me see--
Present.
So yeah, we've got this beacon
streams to Pub/Sub, to data
flow, and then Bigtable.
And for the batch
data, we can just
get it streaming in
right from cloud storage
or maybe BigQuery.
For the machine learning, we
trained our TensorFlow model
on Compute Engine, and then
we host that with the Cloud
Machine Learning Services.
And on the front
end, we're accessing
that with a Cloud Function.
And this is all
just being hosted
on an App Engine server that's
hitting all of these endpoints.
Yeah, and that's
all I have to demo.
I think we are doing
some questions now?
SHANE GLASS: All right, let's
have a big round of applause
for Billy.
Billy, I was actually afraid
that was a gateway computer
that you were bringing
over here, so.
BILLY: Yeah, I was like, oh,
it looks like a whole computer.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah.
So do we have any questions?
We have microphones over
here on stage left and right.
Please come on up and
ask your questions.
BILLY: Now this was the first--
this week was the
first I actually
got to see one of the
sensors in person.
So that was pretty cool.
SHANE GLASS: All right,
well, in that case,
I'll ask you a question.
BILLY: All right, go ahead.
SHANE GLASS: How do you guys
differentiate and understand
what the impact of natural
disasters like wildfires
are compared to what you would
see in a normal, kind of,
high traffic environment?
BILLY: I'm not sure of that.
So we were able to get this data
from an internal team that's
working with Acclima who
provided the sensors.
So they're taking the more
scientific initiative,
doing data processing,
and cleaning up the data
as it's coming in.
We were able to just hook
in to their live data
stream and their historical
data, and they have big plans.
They're going to add more cars
and do more analysis with that.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, so the plan
is then to, kind of, bring this
out further and expand it?
BILLY: Yeah, I think
in the coming months,
they're going to be adding
maybe 20 cars or so.
And that's just in the Bay Area.
I think the goal is to expand
to other areas, other countries,
and see where things go.
SHANE GLASS: All right, so
what should the good folks here
in front of us be looking
forward for after that?
BILLY: After that?
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, like what
would they see from this view
as that happens?
BILLY: As that happens.
Well, hopefully more
points will be filled in,
because right now we can
only see where the cars are.
But that's also, kind
of, why we wanted
to show the machine learning.
So the cars can't be
everywhere all the time,
so how can we create a heat
map of where the cars might
have been that past
year around that time
or based on the other
points around there.
SHANE GLASS: Awesome.
So we have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so I was wondering
with the data you've gathered
are there any sort of findings
that you've concluded in terms
of health implication in
certain areas of the city
or if there are any sort of
rise in asthma because there's
like CO2 that's like
aggregated and [INAUDIBLE]..
BILLY: I think there
have been a few--
thanks for your question.
I think there have been a few
more like scientific papers
written about some
of this information.
And I don't have the answer
based on that though.
So I can just grab you
after and point you
in the right direction on that.
SHANE GLASS: Are there
any other questions?
OK, all right.
Well, Billy, thanks so much.
We really appreciate your demo.
Let's hear it again for Billy.
BILLY: Thanks for having me.
Can I grab this?
SHANE GLASS: OK, yeah, we
appreciate your holding
questions, and we're asking
these folks to go really fast.
Because that's the fun of
Demo Derby is it's a derby.
So yeah, feel free to come
on up during the session
and, kind of, cue up
and ask your questions.
Speaking of which, we
are real lucky to have
our next presenter developer
advocate here at Google, Zack.
ZACK: Hello everyone.
My name is Zach.
I'm a developer advocate
for machine learning.
I'm based in London,
and does anyone
want to guess where
my accent is from?
No one has ever gotten it right.
AUDIENCE: Ireland.
ZACK: OK, that
person got it right.
Yeah, I'm from Ireland, and
I like machine learning.
And I've built a really cool
machine learning detector,
and it's pretty obvious
what it is, right.
Like, I think it's
spelled correctly.
So a bit about me.
I'm Zack.
I build stuff.
I build stuff that matters.
This is a decisive
thing that will
decide if you should eat
something that's on your desk
or not.
You can find a bit more
about that on my Twitter.
But I want to talk about what
I built for this Demo Derby.
And I don't know about you,
but I love tech videos.
Who here likes tech videos?
Like everyone.
Yeah, of course.
I love tech videos.
And I work in tech.
It's great.
I get to hear tech,
tech, tech all day long.
But when I go home
I watch tech videos,
but it's just like there's
too much tech jargon in them.
Am I right?
Like, I want to
watch the tech video.
I want to get all
the techie goodness,
but I don't want to
hear about the tech.
I want the tech video
without the tech.
Yeah, everyone has
this sort of problem?
Yeah, I want tech
videos without the tech,
and so luckily I've
managed to glue together
some tools to achieve this.
Now I don't know if you've
been on the floor yet,
but if you've been over
near the AI section,
we actually have a demo that
shows our Video Intelligence
API.
Who here has used the
Video Intelligence API
or heard of it?
A couple of people, yeah.
So we had this demo,
and it shows us some
of the capabilities of the API.
And one of them is
object tracking.
So it'll do, sort of, a
base object detection,
and it'll do all that for you.
You don't need to
train the model.
But it also does this cool
thing, which is transcription.
So if you've ever used
the text to speech,
it's basically the exact
same API that runs alongside.
But it just saves you
having to scrape out
the audio from your video file.
So you give it-- you give it the
video, tell it transcribe it,
and it will do it.
The cool thing about it is
that when it transcribes it,
not only does it tell you
the whole block of text
that is in the video, but
it will tell you per word
when each word was said
at a specific second time.
So this is interesting.
I could potentially
use this to maybe build
an app that will find the words
that I didn't want to hear
and maybe beep them out for me.
So that's cool.
I could potentially do that.
But hearing the
words is one thing.
I mean, seeing the
person move their lips
to the word, that's just
as bad as hearing the word.
Because speaking in conferences,
you learn a bit of lip reading.
So is there some other tool
that we can use to solve this?
So we had the Vision API.
And what that does
if you've used it,
if you upload an image of a face
and tell it you're not a robot,
it will detect the individual
points of your face for you.
And it'll do this with
pretty good accuracy.
So then the task is simple.
We take the Video Intelligence
API, transcribe it,
detect the words we don't want
to hear, run the Vision API,
find the position of the mouth,
and then with that information
we can beep out the audio
and beep out the mouth.
So I've recruited
my friend, Greg--
or not Greg.
Oh, that's terrible, Gabe.
Gosh that's recorded.
So Gabe is a good
friend of mine.
I've known him years.
This is him.
I've taken this video today.
He built this really
cool edge demo.
And I got him to say--
so Gabe, what have you built?
GABE: We've built a demo that's
doing vision intelligence
with a model that we've
built in AutoML on GCP,
and it compiles down
to OCR classification
to run on our demo.
It compiles it down
to the edge TPU
so that we can run it locally.
ZACK: That's a great video.
It's far too techie
for my liking.
So I've run the video through
this pipeline I've created,
and I enable--
so Gabe, what have you built?
GABE: We've built a demo that's
doing vision intelligence
with the model that we've
built in AutoML on [BEEP]..
And it compiles down to
[BEEP] classification
to run on our demo.
It compiles it down
to the edge [BEEP],,
so we can run it locally.
ZACK: So that's my demo.
Thank you.
SHANE GLASS: Hey,
that's awesome.
Thanks, Zack.
I think that's
actually the first time
that I've ever seen you confirm
that you're not a robot.
So that's actually a
huge relief for me.
GABE: I've heard that before.
SHANE GLASS: Does anybody
have any questions?
Crickets.
You just did such a
good job explaining it.
That must be what it is.
I gotta admit it's
not every day that you
see someone forget the name
of a guy with blue hair.
ZACK: I know, yes.
It's embarrassing.
I actually have a
question for myself.
SHANE GLASS: OK, please.
I would love to hear
your inquisition, sir.
ZACK: OK, so this demo was
built for my specific use
case of not hearing certain
tech words that I don't like.
The real use case
that I initially
came up with as
you may or may not
have come to that
conclusion yourself
is that in the speech
transcription API,
they have a little
flag that will
detect any profanity
or swearing that's
in the video transcription.
And it'll label it with
asteriskes, asterisksi,
strokes, stars.
They'll label it with stars.
So you can run the exact same
pipeline that I've created here
but have it bleep out
the swear words for you.
So that was the
original use case.
SHANE GLASS: And I
thought the coolest
thing was going to
see this week was
that picture of a black hole.
ZACK: I know, well.
SHANE GLASS: Well, this
is cooler obviously.
ZACK: Of course, it is.
Of course, it is.
SHANE GLASS: OK,
well as someone who
does not like hearing
the tech words
and much prefers hearing
that high pitched beep,
I really appreciate it.
So let's hear it for Zach.
Thank you very much.
ZACK: Thank you.
Should I unplug this?
Should I unplug?
SHANE GLASS: OK, vamp.
So how's it going?
So I was told I wasn't allowed
to do a comedy show today.
Obviously, we're going to
cancel the last two demos,
and that's what's
going to happen.
So I just flew in
from Pittsburgh,
and boy are my arms tired.
How about that
airplane food though?
Yeesh, tough crowd.
All right, let's not do this.
Let's go back to the demos.
As we're getting
set up here, let's
hear a huge round of applause
for the team that put together
dev zone, the dev zone theater.
This was an awesome event
that gave us an opportunity
to get the communities
together, to experiment,
to categorize our
pizza correctly,
and to celebrate Pi Day.
So huge shout out to the teams
that worked so hard on that
and made that happen.
Without any further ado, let me
get out of the way, the cat--
Ben, it's all you.
BEN: Hi, so I didn't actually
get the memo that we were
supposed to have intro slides,
and so my name is Meepy Bingo,
and I'm a cat with
a snorkeling thing.
Anyway, so my name is Ben.
I'm a developer advocate
on the DevOps team.
One of the things I'm
interested in is monitoring.
And in particular, I'm
interested in system
monitoring, basic
sysadmin stuff.
So we have Stackdriver.
Stackdriver's pretty cool.
But a problem that
I have with it
is that you only get
data once a minute.
So it's a 60 second
interval, which is fine most
of the time for historical
graphs and stuff like that.
But sometimes you want to know
what's happening in real time.
Real time like--
real time metrics
are very important for
debugging in a hurry and also
like our brains are very
good at pattern recognition.
And so if we see
graphs all the time
when there's an
anomaly on the graph,
your brain is going
to recognize it.
Because your brain
knows something's
not right here, because
it's used to the pattern
that it's used to seeing.
And so you can do
that with this.
But if you have those
graphs in real time,
you get that feedback
much quicker.
And so I've always
been interested in how
do you get information out of
these things and into something
that you can actually
see in the real world.
I'm also interested in doing
extremely stupid demos,
and so I built you this box.
This is the
[? Graphomap ?] 3,000.
I know it's going to be
a little bit hard to see,
but I'll show you a little
bit better in a second.
So it's got these nine
buttons on it that light up,
and they represent
different metrics.
So across the top, there's
user system and I/O 8 CPU.
The second row is memory
usage in just regular usage
and then buffers and cache,
and then the bottom row
is disk and network I/O.
So how many people--
the developer
keynote yesterday, you
saw the thing about pi?
Yeah, excellent.
So I thought I'd do a
little bit of that just to--
it's a good way to tax a
system to really, kind of,
show what that system can do.
So I've got Y Cruncher here.
This is what Emma used
to do the pi thing.
And I'm going to run it.
And I'm going to run just
basic multi-threaded benchmark.
Keeps everything in RAM.
And it'll start running,
and in a couple of seconds
we should see this
went red, right.
Nice.
So that's telling me that
I'm using a lot of CPU.
So if this was just
like sitting on my desk,
it'd be like, all right, cool.
That's a lot of CPU.
I don't really know
what that means.
So I can just hit the button
and wait a couple seconds,
and it's very slowly
printing me out a graph.
Oh, god.
That's bad.
Sorry.
Go, go, it's going to go away.
All right, so here's a graph.
Let me see if I can
fix that real quick.
I would like to say that in
the time tested demo thing,
I didn't even have time
to commit this code.
You saw that we
brought the laptop
up here right as I got on stage,
whereas everyone else already
had their laptops on
screen or on stage.
That's because I was working on
this literally until just now.
All right, so here is
a graph of CPU usage.
Thank you.
So the other thing--
the other thing that
Y Cruncher can do
is it can do stress testing.
So you can say it's got all
these stress tests built
in that allows it to really work
different parts of the system.
And you can see those
little bar graphs
as like this one is
more memory intensive.
This one's more CPU intensive.
So this is just the
same thing, but I
wanted to show you that this
box actually does something
more than just that one thing.
So it should be--
I don't know if you're
going to be able to see.
It's going to be turning yellow
at some point and then red
as it gets started.
My favorite part
of demos is when
you wait for something
that might not happen.
So oh, it looks like we've
got some colors, yeah.
Yeah, all right cool.
Well, let's get a memory graph.
This kind of debugging tool
is really, really handy
for situations where you know
that you've got a problem
and your infrastructure
is on fire,
but you're not actually
in a hurry to fix it.
So there we go, a little
memory usage graph.
So what I want-- like, oh, god.
Go away.
Yeah, so like what
I'm interested in here
is getting data out of
your monitoring system
and putting in front of
you in some way that's
actually more useful than just
having graphs on the screen.
So maybe you have the
classic kind of traffic light
that shows your build status.
Maybe you have a
bunch of view meters
or some kind of like
displays in your office
that show you the
status of your system.
It's important to have that
stuff in front of your eyes
all the time so that when
something goes wrong,
you see it before the
computer tells you about it.
So this is a stupid demo of
something you can do like that,
but take these ideas
and do something
more interesting with them.
I guess I didn't tell you
how it actually works.
This is really special, again,
in the whole live demo thing.
So what's happening is this
has a Raspberry Pi in it that
is tethered to my phone and
is opening a reverse SSA
tunnel to a machine that
I have running in GCP.
My laptop I'm SSHed
to that machine,
and then through the tunnel
back down the Raspberry Pi
to run stuff manually
because I didn't have time
to figure out how to set up the
services and stuff like that.
Net data is running on
the pi calculator machine
to get real time info.
There's also data
from Stackdriver.
But like I said, you've got
that 60 second interval.
So we're getting real
time data from net data,
and then we can look at the
graphs from Stackdriver.
And when you hit a button,
it's pulling that data
and printing out a graph.
So that's how that all works.
I really recommend not
doing it how I did it
but doing something like that.
So any questions?
SHANE GLASS: All
right, let's hear it--
all right, let's hear--
let's hear it for Ben.
BEN: Thank you.
SHANE GLASS: All right,
so just real quick
can you-- how many digits
of pi did you calculate?
BEN: Oh, that's a good question.
Let's look.
SHANE GLASS: And
the reason I asked
I was doing the math
along in my head.
I wanted to see who got further.
BEN: Yeah, so let's see.
Probably I'm going
to guess somewhere
in the vicinity of 4,783.
SHANE GLASS: Yeah, I got to
like six, so I think you won.
BEN: That's awesome.
Cool.
Yeah.
SHANE GLASS: All
right, any questions?
All right, thanks so much, Ben.
All right, the last demo
of the last Demo Derby
here in the dev zone theater--
last but certainly
not least, Alexi.
ALEXI: Hey Everyone.
My name's Alexi.
I'm a DA.
I'm based in Paris.
And I sometimes use
slide I have to--
I'm sorry, spreadsheets,
I have to admit.
And sometimes I do
things like that, import,
and go and look maybe on my
file system and have some CSV,
open this and then go
through some formatting.
Yes, I want this.
And it's really error
prone, and I thought maybe
we could automate this.
And maybe as soon as some
data is ready in CSV format,
I can drop this in a
bucket in cloud storage
and put through some
magic of Cloud Functions,
I can have this data
just automatically
appear in my spreadsheet.
So let's see if we can get to
do all of this from a project
that I may or may not have
been using and testing,
but other than that it has
just two storage buckets
and that's all there is to it.
It's a brand new
project and see if we
can build a cloud function
that will put the data straight
into that spreadsheet.
So the thing that I did do is
enable the Google Sheets API.
That's great.
I said that I did have a bucket.
That bucket is empty,
and this is where I
will be dropping my CSV files.
So let's actually go
to Cloud Functions.
How many people are
using Cloud Functions?
Just a few?
Oh, actually quite a few.
So let's create
a function that I
will call here a sheet of data.
Can I type?
Yeah, that looks great.
This is triggered on stuff
being uploaded to a bucket.
So this sounds like
the right trigger.
Let me pick a bucket
here, select that.
And let's use node, right.
Let me show you a little
bit of the code here.
This is the default snippet.
What I have is something a
little bit more involved.
So let's look at this.
This is my function.
It's an async function.
It will just check that the
meta data that's passed to me,
which is the file that has been
uploaded, is actually CSV file.
I will get some authorization
and initialize a sheets API.
And then I'll do a
few basic things,
which is create a
new sheet, which
is a new tab and a spreadsheet,
read the data in the CSV
format, and then
populate the sheet.
And those two things I can do
in parallel and do some styling
and make sure I just freeze the
first column-- the first line.
And the way this is done
is fairly straightforward,
especially when reading
from Cloud Storage.
The way you talk
to the Sheets API
is by sending JSON
requests basically.
So in this case, I
will send something
that asks to talk to this
spreadsheet, which in this case
is a variable that will
be passed to the function
as I create it.
And then I have a bunch of
code, which is documented,
and I'll tell you
how to get to it.
So let's actually
create that function.
Let's go and also
express some dependencies
that it requires,
which are typically
the storage and the
Sheets API and say, OK.
I need to tell it which
actual function to execute.
This is [? function2 ?] sheet.
This is what I call it.
And there's one more
thing that I need to do,
actually two more things.
OK, this region works for me.
This thing is important.
This is the service account.
This is the user that will
be basically accessing
the sheet on the
behalf of this app.
So we'll get to that in a
second, but remember this.
What I do need to add--
and this is kind
of a variable that
can be changed without
touching the actual function is
the spreadsheet ID.
So let me type this
spreadsheet ID,
and the spreadsheet
ID is actually
if you know this guy in the
URL of any Google spreadsheet.
So let's just take
this and paste it here
and create the function.
So this will take a few seconds.
The code that I have here
I can show you just briefly
how it uses the Sheets API.
And for instance, when I
want to do some reformatting,
I can do things such as give
it a sheet ID, which is the tab
ID that I have, and then
do some styling, which
is get some things that's
bold, some font size,
and do a number of things
that might be useful here.
If I go to the project,
remember that service account?
There's one that's
created for me by default.
So let's actually take that
email address, which is, again,
the service account that
is used by the project
to access the sheet and
give it access to my sheet.
So just as you would
invite any particular user,
give it edit access, and just--
actually, I'm sending this.
I probably shouldn't share this.
There's no human being
behind-- this is my project.
And as I do this, let's go
back to the function that
has been deployed.
And let's see if this
thing actually works.
Let's go to my
bucket, and let's see
if I can drop something here.
Like, take CSV file, which is
a few hundred kilobytes, which
will translate into
a few thousands
or maybe tens of
thousands of lines.
And oh wait, there's
a new tab here.
And it just takes this
name, and here's the data.
So what I did here is--
thank you.
I do have some formatting
here, freezing the first row,
making things bold.
And that's it.
My business users or
myself can actually start
and making sense and
dicing and slicing the data
and using all the
powerful features
that Sheet [INAUDIBLE].
And that's what I have
for you as a demo,
and this is actually
fully documented.
And there's even
a code lab so you
can follow step by step
through everything I just did
and tailor this to your needs.
Thank you very much.
SHANE GLASS: All right,
thanks so much, Alexi.
As you said, the function
uses JSON to talk to Sheets.
I'm glad there's a
step-by-step guide.
It's Shane proof,
and because I usually
talk to Sheets by
muttering under my voice
to myself in a way that
might require Zack's demo.
Are there any
questions in the room?
Awesome.
Well, thanks so much, Alexi.
And let's have another
round of applause
for Alexi and for all the great
speakers that we had today.
All right, well,
before we go I'm
going to hand it back
out to [INAUDIBLE]..
But I just want to say thanks
so much for coming out.
We hope y'all enjoyed Next.
We hope y'all enjoyed the Demo
Derby and enjoyed a little bit
of-- a little piece
of the Google culture.
So go forth and do great things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]